what was like the first visual novel
that you played then
that you would consider not going
through your trashy aerogay
teenager phase oh my god this is hentai
i think
the first one i played knowing exactly
what it was and enjoying the [ __ ] out of
it was
canon canon yeah because
i think it was weird right i kind of
discovered the canon visual novel
after i watched air right and what is
this stuff by the way okay so
no idea it's it's from the same guys
from the same people i know that
yeah so before clan ad visual arts made
a number of games one of them being
air which uh i watched the anime of and
i first discovered what
visual arts is and i was like oh i want
to see oh this is based off a game
i couldn't find i remember i couldn't
find the air visual novel anywhere right
but i found canon which is the first
game that they ever made
so i played canon and of course if you
know the story of canon i cried like a
[ __ ]
obviously yeah i was like the first time
in my life i was like
wow visual novels are really [ __ ]
long
because canon not only has like seven
different endings
but just to get to one ending it takes
about 30 hours almost like a book
it is yeah it's like reading seven
different books at once that's how they
get you man
i meet people who play the same visual
novel over and over again and i'm like
what's wrong with you i mean i did that
go outside you've got to get all the
rules go and do something productive
dude i play
just to get to the true ending it takes
like 200 hours oh my god but
you did that yeah because i was so
because i was so invested in the story
because once you get inv that's the
thing with the secret vision
how the [ __ ] do you have the patience of
that that's 15. because i because
because i used to read a lot of books
because you find time you you i think
what do you do as a 15 year old as a 15
year old like 200
means nothing halo just came out i think
for me like it's
i didn't want to be like this normie
scum who play halo i wanted to be a
different boy i wanted to embrace my
weird bro
there was nothing better than pissing
your friends off at school by like
destroying all their [ __ ] like shooting
that i mean
yeah i mean i would do that at school
but then i would come home and be like
you know what
i miss you nagisa i want to know what
happens to you baby
okay i had friends in my friend group
who we would always play xbox together
but there's always that one friend we
were great friends with
never hear from when he goes home and
you were that i
i realized the auto function so i didn't
even have to click anything i was just
i was just sitting but i was like
watching a movie i was like hell yeah
dude let's go it's just like
watching a movie with extra words i
don't think i'd be able to play a visual
novel like that now though no no because
unfortunately
it's like watching anime nowadays right
right you can't watch an anime that's
over like 13 episodes without having to
fully commit
right and it's unfortunate because like
especially in the last couple of years i
know there's been some [ __ ] amazing
visual novels that have come out which
i know if i put the time in i would
[ __ ] love yeah but
it's just unfortunate now that a lot of
these take like 100 plus hours and i
know i would have
no time sounds like hell to me this
sounds like that's a question to you
than kong did you not play
doki doki when that came out no you you
missed the doki doki cross i just didn't
i saw it and i was like cool girl kills
herself everyone's happy about it doki
doki though i would recommend because
it's only like
five six seven the shorter one right
yeah yeah yeah it's like a good
gateway one which is because when that
blew up i just had
undertale flashbacks on youtube when
that yeah it was like because it was
that kind of audience that was getting
attracted to it
and i'm like people are only attracted
to this because this is the first time
they're seeing anything remotely
gorgeous yeah
like that's it i guarantee yeah exactly
like i'm sure there's way better visual
novels than doki doki right yeah oh 100
oh yeah right right exactly
but to them it was like the first time
that they were playing it's like a
visual novel
that was also like kind of mind trippy
and i'm like you guys clearly haven't
played saiyan utah because that's what i
[ __ ] you up i was about to say i think
like a good
i don't know a good gateway and not good
gateway visual novel is cyano utah yeah
because that's the vision of all that
just hits the ground running you know
what i mean like it has a
really interesting concept yeah but it
it is [ __ ] up
so this is a visual novel written by
genna robuchi who is the same guy who
wrote madoka magicka fate
zero uh psychopaths and the concept
is about this guy i think he wakes up
and then i think he waits
yeah i can't remember the exact
beginning because the concept is there's
just
there's just this guy who who i think
you know
he all he sees is just this hellish
landscape
okay like it's it's it's like grotesque
like there are like intestines america
i'm sorry i'm gonna get killed there's
just like intestines on the walls and
just like
veins popping out it's very genuine yeah
it's like this
it's like a scene from silent hills or
something like some of the most hellish
scenes from silent hills
um and the only thing that's normal is
this like one
little lolly that's just like she's the
only
normal thing in this hellish landscape
because if like every other person
is just like uh it's just this like also
hellish blob that he can't understand
so the only thing he the only person he
can communicate with
is this lolly and then that to me just
drew me in
immediately right because it was like
it's cool because it was like yeah
what's going on damn why why why is it
this way and like
the the way that's that's what i look
for in a vision of it because
a lot of visual a lot of the problems i
see with a lot of vision novels doki
doki included
is that the beginning is like very
similar where it's just like ah here's a
high school
normal setting here's his all the
characters and you know it
it takes that time to get invested in
the story right once you do it's [ __ ]
great yeah
but sayonara uta if you can handle a bit
if
if you're not squeamish then uh and you
know you can handle a bit more
you know your stomach's a bit stronger
if you can get past the gore sano does a
fantastic visual noise it's a great
story great characters everything about
is awesome